Department of Justice has filed an
arrest warrant for Hosea Garcia's oh I'd
say the illegal immigrant who was being
tried for the 2015 shooting death of
Kate Steinle Surratt say who had been
previously deported five times was
accused of shooting Steinle with a
stolen weapon then subsequently dumping
the gun in the bay and fleeing the scene
of the crime according to US immigration
officials the federal government plans
to immediately deport all day as soon as
he is released from custody this comes
after a jury found Jose Garcia Zarate
not guilty of murder involuntary
manslaughter and assault with a deadly
weapon sriracha was only convicted of
being a felon in possession of a firearm
a charge that could result in time
served following the verdict President
Trump
issued a series of tweets quote a
disgraceful verdict in the Kate Steinle
case
no wonder the people of our country are
so angry with illegal immigration the
Kate Steinle killer came back and back
over the weekly protected Obama border
always committing crimes and being
violent and yet this info was not used
in court his exoneration is a complete
travesty of justice build the wall the
jury was not told the killer of Kate was
a seven-time felon the Schumer Pelosi
Democrats are so weak on crime that they
will pay a big price in the 2018 and
2020 elections just moments ago on
Tucker Carlson tight Attorney General
Jeff Sessions also weighed in watch this
it's time for this country to get his
head on straight
these cities should not be protecting
criminal aliens we're able to come into
the country unlawfully then they commit
another crime and then they hide that
individual and don't let them as they
did with the sapota be turned over to
the ice officers so they can be properly
deported so we think the killer and he
is the killer is now being deported that
will be his ultimate fate we are
confident and we are going to do
everything possible to ensure that
happens although there are some
potential other charges that could be
brought against him and before being
deported and released we think he should
face every charge that
is proper to be brought against him and
you can be sure our Department of
Justice is working right now to bring
any charges that are appropriate all
right fantastic all right joining us now
is Fox News contributor Charlie Hart Fox
News legal analyst Gregg Jarrett and Fox
News contributor David Webb thank you so
much for joining us
tonight gentlemen you can ruin Gregg I'm
gonna begin with you earlier today you
wrote an op-ed for Fox news.com titled
the signle verdict there's only the
latest miscarriage of justice in San
Francisco
what do you mean by that if you look at
the history of what juries have done in
San Francisco it goes all the way back
to when I was a law student in two
blocks away as I was sitting in class
the mayor of San Francisco and a board
of supervisor were gunned down by a guy
by the name of Dan white
his lawyers concocted the most
preposterous defense I've ever heard of
the so-called Twinkie defense a diet of
junk food led him to be aggressive and
violent the jury swallowed it hook line
and sinker and they acquitted him of
murder he was convicted of manslaughter
only did five years and was set free I
mean there has been a consistent pattern
in San Francisco of liberal juries
letting people go notwithstanding the
law and the facts unbelievable United
that that case brings back you know just
a frightening memories and then working
as a prosecutor in San Francisco you
could see the juries do some
unbelievable things I didn't even expect
David that they would do what they did
here with this Kate Steinle verdict it
was really shocking well sadly I think
you could have predicted this based on
what Greg said there's a history of this
and it's also a problem in liberal
policies in something that has turned
our our correction system from punitive
into one that is based on excuses it was
your bad upbringing it was the Twinkie
defense it was something else that
caused you to do this it was someone
else that picked up the gun it was
someone else that did this the fact is
they excused the behavior and and look
my heart breaks for this family a father
and a daughter walking along taking a
selfie to wind up dead because someone
who should not have been in this country
no matter what
was on the street in a city that
protected him these aren't sanctuary
cities these are refuge cities they are
refuge cities and we're in a budget time
right now and the one thing the Trump
administration should do is tie
conditions to the budgets to these
cities to the federal monies and if they
don't comply by next Friday the 8th when
they have to get this through they
should make sure that they keep the
money from them if they don't comply
with federal law all right Charles so
obviously the president very upset you
see some strong words with the decisive
specific action delineated by our
Attorney General Jeff Sessions you this
is such I think a miscarriage of justice
and I think Sean Hannity was correct
when he said last night these sanctuary
cities you know they have blood on their
hands oh absolutely it's a total
travesty of justice and then to add
insult to injury we saw that lawyer for
this this this thug this bum come out
afterwards and instantly try to
politicize all of it and he talked about
how Donald Trump needed to respect the
jury decision because he's under
investigation or some nonsense like that
it was just it was absolutely insulting
but if he wants to politicize it okay
let's have a political fight about this
and you know that's what we had in the
last election and Donald Trump won and
the reason that he won is because this
is not a 50/50 55/45 issue this is like
an 8020 issue Americans are so sick and
tired of this kind of crap out of
Washington out of the federal government
failing to do its most basic essential
job that that this is a great this is a
great issue for Republicans if they want
to and if Democrats want to defend
sanctuary cities defend people like this
defend lawless people from just poring
over the border committing acts like
this and then getting protected then
fine let's have that fight and you know
what Republicans will win in the next
election and then Donald Trump will win
reelection I'm fine with that let's have
that but let's continue to have this
political debate if they want to you
know Kimberly there's a point to be made
here and I want Americans to be a very
close attention to this liberals and
liberal progressives are willing to
sacrifice American lives yet for their
political goals pay close attention to
what they
say they sacrifice eachother they
sacrifice American lives and their
ideologies is dangerous to everyone out
there
what's inexplicable is the Department of
Justice the feds never prosecute under
the laws 21 years ago Congress passed a
law that said it's illegal not to
cooperate with ice and yet you have 300
sanctuary cities and County San
Francisco included who abused that law
they ignore that law and there's another
law that says if you harbor or shield
somebody who's here illegally that's a
crime five years behind bars and if
somebody dies like Kate Steinle as a
result of what the city and county did
in San Francisco its life behind bars
the sheriff who let that man walk out of
the jail and kill Kate Steinle should
have been prosecuted and should be doing
life behind bars
but the feds won't touch it Jeff
Sessions needs to get off his Duff okay
well let's see that he definitely a call
to arms for Jeff Sessions to do
something about this and also obviously
would be in keeping with what the
president wants to do Greg I'm gonna
double back with you because I'm
California Governor Jerry Brown recently
signed the bill a designating Talia
Moonbeam remember California's sanctuary
states right talk to us about that well
oddly enough as as restrictive and
abusive and illegal as that is because
under the Supremacy Clause federal
government has the final say and
province over matters of immigration
Jerry Brown is thumbing his nose at the
law but San Francisco's is even more
restrictive than the state sanctuary
policy and both ought to be prosecuted
by the feds you know there's a serious
and significant you know loss of life
and you hear the stories in the news and
you meet the mothers and the fathers and
the family members who have suffered at
the hands of crimes committed by illegal
immigrants who come into this country
revolving door you know exhibiting
recidivism repeated crimes career
criminals and yet it seems like
nothing's done about it David
know nothing
none about it and I want to add another
context to this liberal policy of open
borders not doing anything about
immigration they're in effect creating
an underclass in America when you look
at the numbers put out there of illegal
aliens and they are illegal aliens under
18 US Code not on documented immigrants
and you look at the education levels
when they come in with low education
levels or no education levels don't even
meet high school graduation at a minimum
in America that means that we are
creating a segment of this society that
is incapable of participating in this
society effectively we're importing
poverty no matter where they come from
whether it's El Salvador Estonia Eastern
Europe Asia or wherever we are importing
poverty and that is an economically
enviable way to go through and have a
society be successful these liberal
policies will bring this country down
and when we become the country that no
one wants to come to because of these
policies where do their liberal
ideologies go yeah well you know Charles
is it gonna take that long I mean you
talk about the elections coming up and
that the Liberals and the Democrats are
gonna pay for these policies that
ultimately can result in loss of life
like we saw with Kate Steinle gunned
down but there is a reckoning coming in
2018 and in 2020 I think there is but
also you know let's remember how all of
this insanity began in the first place
it began because Democrats couldn't win
any fights
based on the the the you know the the
ideas that they were trying to propose
they all of their issues they couldn't
win any of them and so the only way to
do it was to not change their ideas but
to change the electorate and that's why
they went to this open borders policy
and this idea of bringing in all of the
as David says all of these impoverished
people that don't necessarily have any
skills or anything but just throw the
borders open and and then and basically
treat them as indentured voters so that
they could it could win a high office
again and that's what they've done and
it's war and I'm sad to say it's worked
brilliantly
it's they've succeeded beyond I'm sure
their wildest imaginations and and they
they made up the differences for for
Barack Obama both times and and probably
made the difference in in both of Bill
Clinton's elections and you know it's
it's it's really sinister but it's true
and and not until Americans take back
their country and and fix all of these
problems will you know will this mess
subside and yet the people of San
Francisco Kimberly seem to go along with
all the others we saw that last night
with the jury I mean this was a clear
case of felony murder California law
says you know this California lawyer if
you fire a weapon into an area where
people are and somebody dies that's
felony murder at the very least it was
manslaughter which is the reckless
handling of gun even if you buy his
argument that it was accidental that's
manslaughter
it's outrageous because it was obviously
a total conscious disregard for human
life behaving in this way acting with
essentially an implied malice conscious
to be part of a no rich likely to result
in great bodily yeah but the I saw this
with San Francisco jury sadly and I
prosecute a case in San Francisco in Los
Angeles and it's unbelievable because
you can sit there and charge the jury
and read the jury instructions and they
have a whole different political bent in
terms of how they want to see things
come out and they're thinking more about
outcome than following the law you want
to commit a heinous crime as I said in
my column San Francisco is the place for
you right you'll get away with it my
question to you is this what if they did
what would that jury have done if the if
the roles had been flipped and it was a
legal American how can you a shot and
killed and illegal and then and then
this kind of verdict came out there was
on the Embarcadero there would be
Sherman's war via Sherman's wharf would
be on flame in flames right now but this
is the hypocrisy of liberal ideology it
ignores facts it ignores the rule of law
it ignores the realities of life and
again they're willing to sacrifice
anything to achieve their goal that is
contrary to what we do in America yeah
and Greg real quick and that's why so
many people have asked you know can
President Trump actually for sanctuary
cities to comply with federal law he can
he can do it with you know sort of
carrot and stick
I mean he can heavy with the stick he
could well the stick would be prosecute
people like the sheriff but the the
carrot is really just take the money
away from them there's only one way you
can get through to politicians and take
their federal government funds away from
them and he has the authority under
federal law Department of Justice is
issued an opinion on this and says you
can withhold money they need to start
doing it aggressive and and they have
one week till next week we have this
shutdown showdown battle that's underway
well Congress has a responsibility here
they can tie this they can work with the
administration by next Friday these
could be put in place the restrictions
can be there take their money it's the
only place other than their votes that
they care about yeah you gotta get a
lift the funds lift the wallet and then
they'll pay attention and hopefully
comply we'll see gentlemen thank you so
much